okay here's an interesting voicemail our
number is two one nine two david p with
a very interesting question about where
are all those Obama is going to declare
martial law people right now hey David I
just wanted to say that remember a few
years ago when Obama was president yeah
and he had all those right-wing you're
saying that he was gonna declare martial
law and take away people's guns yes
unleash the Black Hawk helicopters and
all that nonsense right well where are
those people now like I don't get how
they could see what's happening now and
not be against it oh I see how it was
always partisan hackery they never
really care about that stuff
that it's very very simple they're not
complaining now about Trump because when
they see Oh Trump is going to come out
and repress protests with the military
they like it they like it was never
about principles it was never about
suspending habeas corpus or whatever it
was that they said it was just partisan
politics and it's being very boldly
exposed right now we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
bicycles becoming the new toilet paper
they are flying off the shelves during
the corona virus pandemic and much more
don't miss today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
join pakman.com and remember every day
the David Pakman show audio podcast is
available get it on Spotify stitcher
Google Play podcasts iTunes wherever you
want
don't miss the podcast and we will see
you on the bonus show